you think the anger's over no justice no
peace
blm protesters in new york
ran up to some people i guess mostly
white people who were at a restaurant
screaming to the white people get out of
new york
[Applause]
so this guy seems a little bit confused
doesn't he because he's saying
there are a lot of problems with what
he's saying the first is you white man
you white devils we don't want your
taquerias
i say well hold on a second last i
checked taquerias are
they're usually not associated with like
england
right you know they're not they're kind
of a more they're different isn't that
more of a latino kind of thing
or the latinos white i don't i didn't
think that i thought they were people of
color but i guess for the purposes
of this guy screaming at people dining
in the street
then they're white people obviously this
guy
should be arrested this guy should not
this guy who is disturbing the piece
who is making a big nuisance of himself
should
should not be permitted to do these
sorts of things in society a just
society would
would take care of someone like that
but probably i'm not saying even put him
in prison necessarily he should be in an
institution somewhere okay as well as
the maniacs following him
but then to say we don't we we who are
the we is that black people is it i
don't know we
don't want you white people here in new
york
you know white people have been in new
york for a long time
york i isn't i think that name comes
from a place in
england doesn't it does it before new
york was new york it was new amsterdam
amsterdam there are a lot of white
people in amsterdam too just as there
were in new amsterdam
what is the argument here yeah i guess
his argument is that white people
shouldn't
it's not legitimate for them to be in
new york it's unjust for them to be in
new york what
huh no he's not making any argument
though really he's just saying
i don't want you here my will
my base degraded degenerate
lower will is insisting that we kick all
of you people out
and that is now effectively our system
of justice in this country
there will not be peace if that is taken
to be our system of justice there can't
be
because there's nothing to rely on
a great consolation in this world is
even though we all suffer injustices i
know it's very fashionable now on the
blm left
to say that only black people ever
suffer injustice and you know white
people they've got it so good and on the
feminist left only women ever suffer
injustice and
man man we got it so good and only on
the
intersectional sort of sexual left only
homosexuals and
transsexuals and whoever and people have
kind of unusual
sexual behaviors only they have it bad
but
straight people oh man they got it so
good now you know everybody suffers
injustice it's a fallen world and sin
and death pervade the world and a
ballast for us here a great consolation
is that ultimately there is justice
ultimately there is the the ultimate
arbiter the big judge in the sky
right and that our justice system here
on earth
is meant to pursue that that very
justice that very same justice which is
eternal even if
if it is imperfectly applied in this
world
if we lose faith in that because we now
have faith in some bizarre
religious understanding some totally
perverse religious understanding of the
world
then there really will not be any peace
aoc absolutely absolutely right on that
minor point
she's probably cheering it on i think
the rest of us people who are looking at
the situation
with a little more sobriety no one can
celebrate what happened yesterday
whoa whoa whoa whoa where are you going
where hold on you don't need to leave so
fast
first please ring the bell ring the bell
subscribe that way you will never miss a
video that we put out
something tells me that sometimes
youtube would prefer it if you would
miss
videos that we put out so make sure you
subscribe like
really appreciate it we'll see on the
[Music]
next
[Music]
you